ROMAN NURIK: Hello, and welcome,
once again, to
Android Design in Action.
We have a very special episode
for you today about Navigation
Drawers, the new pattern
introduced at Google I/O 2013.
We have some very awesome
members of the
Android design team.
They'll introduce themselves
in a moment.
They're here to talk to you
about the pattern, so that's
going to go on for about
20, 30 minutes or so.
And then we're going to into a
couple of questions that Nick
and I have prepared
for the team about
this awesome new pattern.
So just to quickly introduce
ourselves, my
name is Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: And, hi,
my name is Nick
Butcher, here from London.
JENS NAGEL: Hi, my name is Jens
Nagel, interaction design
on the Android design team.
RICH FULCHER: And I'm Rich
Fulcher, interaction designer
on the Android design team.
And we're both here
in Mountain View.
ROMAN NURIK: Actually, this is
one of my favorite episodes, I
think, so far because we have
folks from Mountain View, New
York and London in the
same video hanging
out at the same time.
So anyway, without further ado,
Rich, Jens, would you
like to take it away?
RICH FULCHER: Sounds great.
I thought we could start by
maybe going through the
history of how the Navigation
Drawer emerged as a pattern.
And kind of going back, I think
kind of the first app
that a lot of people experienced
the Navigation
Drawer in on Android, and
certainly the first Google app
they would have seen
it, was YouTube.
Now that drawer that we saw at
that time is different in a
lot of key ways from the
drawer pattern that we
discussed last month at I/O.
But it still had a lot of the
same original objectives.
To bring content to the
forefront, to get navigation
out of the way and have it only
use screen real estate
when the user was
kind of actively
trying to change locations.
So when we, on the design team,
see a need like that, we
kind of have this natural
instinct to want to turn it
into a pattern that other
applications can make use of.
Because we often see that that
need is not specific to a
given application or service,
but it's something that would
be a benefit to a
larger audience.
So the first step that we do is
we look at a pattern like
that, particularly on Android,
is we like to think about how
that works from a navigation
standpoint.
Android, as you know, is special
in its use of both the
Back button and in Up affordance
in the very
commonly used action
bar pattern.
And as we were looking at the
Navigation Drawer, there were
a lot of different ways we could
have elected to have it
behave in terms of
its interaction
with those two controls.
It could have been that the
drawer always presented itself
the minute you launched an
application, and was kind of,
logically, a screen sitting
above the other screens.
Or it could have been something
that was invoked by
one of the affordances
but not the other.
That Up would trigger
it but not Back.
Or you could even have other
interactions with Back where
making multiple selections or
sequential selections from the
drawer could build up a
continuous back state.
In the end, we went with kind
of a pretty straightforward
model, that the drawer was
invoked off the action bar's
Up affordance in an altered
form, and doesn't relate to
the Back button except
for closing it.
But we like to start with these
broad explorations.
So what you're seeing on the
screen here are some of really
the earliest wire framing work
we did around this drawer
pattern and defining it.
After we considered the
interaction, we like to look
at what the visual storytelling
we're going to do
with these elements could be.
And with the Drawer we had a lot
of different options, even
just thinking about what that
trigger mechanism would look
like to let the user know that
there was a drawer there.
When YouTube first introduced
it, they didn't have any kind
of distinct graphic.
They just relied on the
existing left arrow.
But we thought about, well, what
if we did a special icon
or a glyph to decorate the
application icon that would
denote there's a drawer?
Something like the three
vertical lines that we've come
to affectionately know as the
hamburger internally here.
But there are other options.
It could've been that we used a
right arrow to indicate that
something was emerging
from the side--
from the left side moving
to the right.
Or it could have been a less
special treatment that, when
triggered, used the contextual
action bar flavor so that it
could dismiss it in the same way
that you would dismiss a
selection state.
Again, we try to look at
a range of options.
We always try to think about
many contexts of use, not just
one particular application.
And we try to look for ways to
produce synergy with other
patterns that are already in
use, both for developers and
for us, most importantly, for
users who have certain
expectations based
on what they've
already seen in the platform.
Where we ultimately ended
up was what you've seen.
There's a distinct icon in the
Action Bar and I can touch it
to open it.
But we also put a lot of thought
into what the gestural
mechanisms that could be used
to open this should be.
So we have the edge
swipe available.
It's really a short cut
at the top level.
It does the exact same action
that hitting the
Action Bar would do.
But it really comes into its
own on lower levels of the
application where that Action
Bar space is being used for
hierarchical up, and then the
edge swipe can be an immediate
way to access that control
from deeper within the
application.
JENS NAGEL: All right.
The Navigation Drawer is really
a new way of switching
top levels inside of your app.
There have been, already,
established patterns in
Android such as the six pack,
for example, the spinner or
the fix tabs that you as
developers are probably very
familiar with.
That serve a similar purpose.
Let's look at that real quick.
Basically what they do is they
allow you to switch between
the top level.
So if you look at a really
boiled down diagram of an app,
the top level is basically the
screens that represent the
different facets of your app,
and sort of have the function
to represent the major use cases
of your app and sort of
guide you down through the
connecting screens down to the
consumption level.
What you can see is that what
those patterns have in common
is that they only represent
themselves at the top level.
So be it the six-pack or be it
the tabs, they all rely on a
piece of user interface or a
piece of Chrome, that lives in
particular at the top level.
Once you navigate away from
that, that switching
opportunity goes
away from you.
And if you want to switch back
to a different facet, you
actually have to navigate
up to the top level.
And that is actually one of
the key differences to the
Navigation Drawer.
So if you were here, for
example, the Navigation Drawer
does include all the top level
stuff, at the very minimum.
But it now also can include
screens at the lower levels.
So basically, we're thinking
about those
as navigation hubs.
Basically places that users will
want to frequently visit
often or use as a jump off point
to other places in the
application.
So if you wanted to look at
when to use the Navigation
Drawer, as opposed to the other
patterns that we talked
about earlier, here are some
helpful statements, or helpful
guides that can help you
make this decision.
One of those could be more
than three top levels.
So the Navigation Drawer is
particularly good at showing
more content, exposing more
content, than the other top
level switching mechanisms.
If you have more than three top
levels, Navigation Drawer
becomes a possible choice.
If you have less than
[INAUDIBLE] you can also look
at other top level switching
mechanisms, such as taps, for
example, that are very good at
exposing the different facets
of your app within one view.
Also, if you have deep
navigation hierarchies, the
Navigation Drawer is
a good choice.
And here's the reason why.
We've seen that, as you navigate
away from the top
level, usually in an app that
uses the traditional top level
switching mechanisms, you
would have to do some
considerable navigation effort
to get back to the top level,
and then switch over to a
different facet of your app.
The Navigation Drawer helps
you here in that it is
available from anywhere in the
app, and you can just, through
a site swiping gesture, bring
it on screen and navigate
freely to pretty much
anywhere in the app.
Also, if your navigation hubs
are at deeper levels, the
Navigation Drawer is
a good choice.
So for example, if one of your
facets, basically, has
navigation hubs at different
levels, it makes sense to
include them in the Navigation
Drawer in order to jump
quickly into those
deeper levels.
If you have a need for cross
navigation, meaning that you
want to quickly jump from one
facet, maybe at a deeper
level, to another facet that
also has a deeper level,
Navigation Drawer allows you to
do that by including those
deeper navigation targets
inside of the drawer.
Since your Navigation Drawer
has more content, the
Navigation Drawer gives you also
options to structure your
content better.
So you can, for example, as you
can see here, you can add
headers, dividers, and icons
in order to group certain
areas of functionality better.
We also introduced collapsible
items.
So those are another means of
structuring your content by
adding subordinate items,
typically content items, to
top level items.
Maybe a couple of notes to
some interaction details.
One other thing about the
Navigation Drawer is that it
does not have a lot of
representation on the screen.
So if you look at an app that
has a Navigation Drawer, the
defining characteristic is
really the Navigation Drawer
icon in the top left.
So in order for people to
understand how navigation
works in that particular app,
and that Navigation Drawer is
actually present, we wanted to
make sure that as people
launch an application for the
first time, that they are sort
of confronted with the
Navigation Drawer and sort of
see what options they have,
what sort of the top level
activities are that they can
take advantage of in your app.
So upon first launch, open
the Navigation Drawer.
People then can navigate freely
from there in your app,
or just simply dismiss the
Navigation Drawer and get to
the main content that way.
Once they're beyond that point,
once they have actually
opened the Navigation Drawer
manually for the first time,
on subsequent launches then,
don't show the Navigation
Drawer on launch anymore.
So that way you make sure that
people know that there's a
Navigation Drawer, how
to interact with it.
ROMAN NURIK: One of my favorite
things I wanted to
point out about that was that,
basically, you get the ability
to tell the user about the
gesture, and about the
physical space within which the
Navigation Drawer interacts.
Right?
So if you initially show the
Navigation Drawer, and then
you kind of--
they hide it by either touching
outside the content
area, or touching the upper
coordinates or anything like
that, they basically--
the Navigation Drawer
immediately slides to the
left, and it kind of hints that
if you pull out from the
left, you'll actually
see it again.
So it almost hints at the
gestures involved with that
kind of initial impression
that you get.
JENS NAGEL: Yeah.
In that sense it's a really
important learning step, to
get you familiar with what the
app is really all about.
And, also, how the
Navigation Drawer
actually works and functions.
Then the second thing I wanted
to point out is to give the
user a peak.
And that is really to make the
Navigation Drawer more
detectable and also
more tangible.
If you use the library that we
provide for implementing the
Navigation Drawer, you don't
really need to worry about
this because that's already
automatically taken care of.
And you get this for free.
But what it really does is, as
users explore applications
with their fingers, and then
maybe accidentally touch on
the left edge of the screen,
then your Drawer peeks in a
little bit and sort of gives
you a good affordance, good
feedback, that you can drag the
Navigation Drawer out from
the left onto the rest
of the screen.
Finally, we often get the
question, well, if I use the
Navigation Drawer, should I
have his Navigation Drawer
icon at all levels off my app?
Should it be represented
on all screens?
And the answer is really no.
Only those screens that are
represented in the Navigation
Drawer should actually have
a Navigation Drawer image.
All other screens have the
traditional up caret.
And the reason for that is
really, as we were developing
this, we sort of entertained the
idea of having access to
the Navigation Drawer via the
application icon throughout.
But it really felt like it
creates a separate brand of
applications with a different
navigation model that is not
consistent with other Android
applications that sit side by
side with Navigation Drawer
applications.
So in that sense, we for screens
that are not typical
jump off points, or are not high
value navigation targets,
we keep the up affordance
there intact.
NICK BUTCHER: So just to
interject there, so on those
other screens where you have the
up affordance, it's still
accessible via this
kind of the bezel
swipe, the edge swipe.
Right?
JENS NAGEL: Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
NICK BUTCHER: So in that way
it's kind of like an
accelerator, like a
keyboard shortcut.
So the power users who know
about it, you have this method
of easily pulling up the
navigation from anywhere if
you want, while still retaining
the familiar
navigation, kind
of hierarchical
navigation of the up, right?
JENS NAGEL: Exactly.
It's good that you
mentioned that.
So the Navigation Drawer is
accessible at-- or should be
accessible from all levels.
And the Navigation Drawer image
is really sort of this
short little reminder that
the Navigation Drawer--
or that you're at a place where
navigating away with the
Navigation Drawer is
a likely option.
RICH FULCHER: Yeah.
It's also kind of-- if you had
a application that just used
the up affordance, at that
topmost screen that left
pointing carrot would go away.
And that was kind of an
indication to the user that
you are at a special place,
you're at the kind of logical
top of the application.
The presence of the three line
drawer indicator does much the
same thing now.
You're getting a slightly
different look at what the
action bar is.
And again, it's just kind of
reinforcing, you're at the
home of the app.
You're at this logical place
from which you can go to lots
of different destinations, and
you can use the drawer to
accomplish that.
So now I'd just like to run
through a few examples and we
can talk about some of the
different uses of the Drawer.
And I thought I would just go
through a number of the Google
Apps that have been recently
released that
make use of the Drawer.
The first one is Gmail, which
probably many people are well
acquainted with.
In the latest version
of Gmail, we've
introduced the Drawer.
And the Drawer is used for two
different capabilities.
The most expected one is that
it's used to move between my
inbox and other supporting
labels.
So doing the same kind of
navigation that was previously
available from a spinner in
the primary action bar.
It's also accommodating
the ability to
switch between accounts.
So at the top of the Drawer, you
see the radio button for
the currently active account.
And we would just introduce
more and more of those if
there were more accounts
present.
Using the Drawer as an account
switching mechanism is
something that's used by a
couple of the Google apps.
You'll notice in Google Drive,
for instance, they also
support this.
They use a spinner within the
Drawer in that case, because
the perception is that account
switching is a less frequently
require task for Drive users.
Whereas for Gmail, we have this
stronger presumption of,
if you have these two Google
accounts, you're likely
checking mail in both
of those accounts.
So rather than having a two
touch operation of touch on
spinner to open, touch on
account to transition, we want
to expand those account options
directly into the Drawer.
So we use the radio button
approach there.
The Drawer also makes
use of additional
content for the items.
You're seeing counts of unread
items for each of
the selected labels.
Again, more kind of metadata
that helps guide a user to
which destination they
may wish to go to.
The other thing that's good to
note about the way that Gmail
uses the Drawer, is the way
that the action transforms
when the Drawer is open.
So in it's kind of natural
state, when you're looking at
the Inbox, you have actions
for Compose or for Search.
And those are operations that
relate specifically to that
account that you have present.
You're going to be generating a
new email from that account,
you'll be searching the content
of that account.
Because the Drawer covers
content that could be from
multiple accounts, when we open
that, those actions are
suppressed and they just
disappear from the action bar.
We always want the actions
that you show within the
action bar when the Drawer is
open, to relate to the entire
application context.
So we just kind of remove those
that have a tighter
focus or tighter scope.
ROMAN NURIK: So I had one
quick question, I guess.
So here in Gmail we see the use
of standard hollow list
headers to indicate different
segments or
different sections of labels.
And above that you, obviously,
have the account types, or the
accounts to choose from.
Whereas you guys also talked
about the options that have
collapsible items.
Can you talk a little bit about
the difference when you
would use one versus
the other?
RICH FULCHER: Sure.
Sure.
So for Gmail we just kind of
expand all of those items and
don't use a collapse.
Largely because the relative
ordering of the items within
there kind of naturally supports
the most frequently
used destinations appearing
at the top, and then just
supporting a continuous
scroll, with a very
predictable order to it.
Once I get kind of past my
recent or system level labels,
I'm just in an A to Z listing
of all the labels that I've
created, or that I manage.
So there's not a lot of need, in
that case, to, since it is
really just one collection that
you're opening, to have
more fine grain controls
over that presentation.
If, however, you had a number
of such categories, you
wouldn't want the user to have
to scroll through the full
contents of the second and third
category to get to the
fourth one.
And so in those types of
situations, compacting makes a
lot of sense.
You're using the option to
compact or expand those items
as a way to accelerate the user
getting to the sub items
that they need to reach.
ROMAN NURIK: Makes sense.
Thanks.
RICH FULCHER: Sure.
NICK BUTCHER: While we're
talking about having different
groups of content, and also the
expanding and collapsing
pattern, do you have any
recommendations about the
maximum size?
I mean, you probably wouldn't
want some unbounded list in a
Navigation Drawer, right?
Do you have any guidelines about
where we might stop?
RICH FULCHER: Yeah.
I think the strongest guideline
is that you don't
want to try to replicate all
the data that your app is
trying to express inside
of the Drawer.
Now, if you find that you have a
lot of targets but they have
a very predictable ordering to
them-- so you may have a user
who uses dozens of
labels in Gmail--
that's still a fairly suitable
usage because, again, it's
highly predictable, you
know exactly what
you're going to get.
And the content that you're
trying to express for each is,
kind of, pretty tight.
It's really just a label
and account.
For other situations where you
have more content, where it's
dynamic, where that's changing
on a more regular basis, those
are the kind of things that
I think work less well as
navigation.
And it might just be that you
kind of need to pull those out
and express them in the full
context of your app, rather
than just trying to accommodate
them into the Drawer.
And I would say, in general,
if you don't fit into this
notion of having categories or
well ordered sets of content,
and you're finding that you
have a lot of distinct
navigation destinations within
the Drawer, it might be taking
a little bit--
it might be worth taking a
little step back and kind of
thinking about how you're
structuring your application.
It may, simply, just
be too broad.
There might be ways that you
could, in a sense, lose a
little bit of speed of accessing
this wide breadth of
options, by adding a little
bit more depth to your
application.
And as a result, making it just
more naturally and easily
understood by the user, and
taking advantage of the
relationship between distinct
but related destinations that
maybe want to get presented in a
more combined format further
down the apps hierarchy.
ROMAN NURIK: We've definitely
given folks the feedback in
the past that, hey, your
app is doing too much.
Focus on the couple of things
you can do really well and do
those, and, obviously then
your list of different
sections in the app gets trimmed
down to something
smaller and more manageable.
But we've definitely given the
feedback that maybe this is
multiple apps, or maybe you
should trim out some of the
functionality that
you don't need.
JENS NAGEL: And I think on the
lower end we talked about
three top levels as a
starting point of--
four top levels, I should say,
as the starting point for
using the Navigation Drawer.
You want to make sure that
the Navigation Drawer
is not under populated.
So if you, for example, imagine
Navigation Drawer only
having two items, three items,
it feels too much white space.
It feels too under populated,
and there are other top level
switching mechanisms that could
be a better choice.
RICH FULCHER: That's actually
a great lead into the next
example I wanted to cover, which
is the way that the Play
apps make use of the
Navigation Drawer.
So what you're seeing here are
the Play Music and the Play
Books path.
At the left, Play Music opens
up and it has five different
navigation options.
And could add more.
It's scalable, so as there are
more ways of consuming your
music, we can naturally
suit that in.
That's also, I think,
something that
goes into that decision.
Not just kind of where you are
immediately in your app, but
what you see the road map for
the next version or the
version after that.
So kind of planning ahead for
more significant navigation
needs might also be a good
reason to adopt the Drawer
slightly early.
But in this particular case,
we've got somewhat symmetric
ordering of the options between
these two different
apps, the focus on different
types of media.
They both start with kind of
this now oriented context,
either Listen Now for Music
or Read Now for Books.
They then go into kind of
looking at the way your
library is structured and
ways you can consume it.
Music has more options in that
regard, because it also
supports playlists and
instant mixes.
But it's, still, those
are versions of how
is the content organized?
And both of these Navigation
Drawers then terminate with a
Shop option, which is actually
not even an internal
navigation.
It's a hand off to
the Play store.
By presenting those similar
structures and similar orders
between these different but
related applications, you're
helping the user build up a good
mental model of what they
expect a Play app to feel like,
and how they can quickly
learn ways to navigate them and
apply what they learn in
one context to another.
ROMAN NURIK: One of the nice
side effects, I guess, of
having Shop open up the Play
store, is that, actually, the
Play store also uses the
branded, single accent color
action bar.
Once you jump into the shop for
books area, you actually
get a blue action bar with
the books icon and so on.
Actually, no, it's the Play
icon at the top left.
But there is some kind of
persistence of state.
You're not jumping into
a completely separate
experience.
It's still kind of part of the
same family of products.
RICH FULCHER: Yes, definitely.
And then you're kind of back
navigation away has some
interesting effects
there as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Right.
RICH FULCHER: The next example I
wanted to look at was Google
Earth, which has some slightly
nontraditional usage of the
Navigation Drawer, but I just
wanted to talk about this a
little bit because I think
it's interesting.
The first thing I'll point out
is that Earth doesn't use a
proper action bar.
Because it's a very search
focused activity, it uses that
real estate that you would
expect an action bar to use at
the top, to present a field
where the user can always
touch to put in a destination
that they'd like to refocus
that view upon.
And it doesn't have the standard
actions or overflow
at the right hand side
that a normal
action bar would present.
But it still can present the app
icon, and it can present
the glyph indicating the
presence of the Drawer.
And then touching that
effectively leaves the action
bar in place.
Again, it's not an action bar,
but it's giving it that same
kind of stability that the
Drawer would expect, and just
kind of sliding the content
of the Drawer in, sitting
properly beneath that
pseudo action bar.
Earth uses the Navigation
Drawer, not so much for
navigation, although it does
have elements of that.
In fact, Earth Gallery Target
at the bottom is a proper
navigation link.
But it's using it to, in effect,
filter the view or set
preferences about the level of
detail that you want to see in
the primary view.
Another option for this would
have been to continue to use
the Drawer pattern,
but to rely on a
right hand side Drawer.
Instead of kind of trying to
present it in the traditional
navigation space.
You could present it
at right and make
it more about filtering.
But there are trade offs
involved in that, as well, in
terms of how you indicate the
presence of that Drawer and
how that would affect the
action bar and even the
branding that comes
with having the
app icon at the top.
Relatedly, if you look at the
Google One Today application,
this is an application that's
focused on charitable giving
and encourages users through
a notification, to make $1
donation every day to various
organizations and efforts.
It uses both a left and
a right Drawer.
And I think it does a really
excellent job.
The left Drawer is standard
navigation.
You open it up and you can move
between either looking at
the current offer or other
things like looking at your
profile, your giving history.
The right hand side Drawer is
focused on notifications.
And its invoked either by a
right edge swipe-- a right to
left edge swipe--
or by touching on the
Notification Count action in
the action bar.
And touching there does
the exact same
animation you would see.
So you'd see it kind of slide
in from the side.
Teaching you again that you
can probably perform this
gesture to invoke it, using
the animation to tell that
story to the user about how
that Drawer performs.
And these Drawers actually can
move directly from one to the
other, as well.
Which is--
you're going to play with it
to see the effect, but it's
really neatly done.
They kind of chase each other
at proper speed, and the
animations well implemented.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
So I think that's
all content--
the pre-canned content--
you guys had
about Navigation Drawers.
And obviously, for folks that
are looking to implement this,
couple of quick points.
All the design guidelines are
available on developer.androi
d.com/design/pat
terns/navigation-drawer.
Something like that.
Just go to the design site
and you'll see it there.
And the second thing is, if
you're a developer looking to
implement this, Nick and
I actually did an I/O
presentation on Navigation
Drawers.
Actually, we talked about other
things as well, but the
Android Designed for UI
Developers presentation has
implementation tips.
And also, Rich and Jens, you
guys did a presentation at I/O
about structure and
app design, right.
So this is also well
covered there.
So lots of good resources
outside of this video if
you're looking to implement.
So I think we have about
a few minutes left.
We should probably go through
a couple questions.
I know there's some burning
hot questions from the
community that I wanted
to ask you guys.
We probably have time
for three or four.
Let's start with one of
the popular ones.
So a lot of the community
implementations of Navigation
Drawers out there, actually,
rather than overlaying
content, they slide it out of
the way-- or I guess, they
kind of push it to the side.
Some push the action
bar, some don't.
But our pattern, our
implementation actually
overlays the content.
Can you guys talk a little bit
about the reasoning and the
decision making process
for that?
RICH FULCHER: Sure.
Let me break it into two parts,
because I think there's
kind of two interesting things
that we're looking at pretty
extensively during our
exploration of this.
The first is the question
of keeping the
action bar in place.
And that was a decision
we were able to
come to fairly quickly.
We thought there was a lot
of value to kind of--
even as that Drawer component
comes in, keeping a stable
element that just really speaks
to the identity and the
context that you're currently
within, within the
application.
It gave us the ability to
transform the action set to
open up and show actions that
maybe weren't in the immediate
context, but had global
relevance to the app and could
be convenient accelerators for
things you would want to do
from any context.
So we very early on latched onto
the idea that we'd want
to keep the action
bar present.
We definitely looked a lot at,
should we push the content, or
should we slide the
panel over?
I think we had a gut instinct
that we thought slide was
going to be interesting because
of the desire to--
as Jens talked about before--
of bringing the Drawer
in from deeper
levels of the hierarchy.
That even when the affordance
wasn't there, you'd want to be
able to bring the Drawer in.
And it felt more natural to us
to think of it sliding over as
opposed to existing to the left
of all of these different
spaces of hierarchy.
And more thinking and more
experimentation with that let
us to just, as we were playing
with these different
prototypes--
we always put a strong focus
on the importance of direct
manipulation to the user.
That we want them to feel like,
when their finger goes
down on a device and they start
moving it, that the
content is really strongly
anchored to that, and
responding directly.
If we were to do the push,
there are some conditions
where that wouldn't
feel that way.
So if it's that I have my main
screen and then beside the
Drawer sits and it's just kind
of slightly off screen, well,
if those two are really married
together in that way,
then you would expect that a
drag, a kind of a poll on that
main surface, would bring
the Drawer in naturally.
If we were to do that, then you
wouldn't be able to do the
swipe to do any other action
within that main view.
You couldn't use a view
pager, you couldn't
use swipe to dismiss.
In the Earth example you
couldn't even pan within the
view of the globe that
you're seeing there.
ROMAN NURIK: That would
be a non starter.
RICH FULCHER: Yeah, so we didn't
want to set up this
relationship that didn't feel
authentic, and feel true for
all of these manipulation.
So by saying no, it's an edge
swipe, and that's pulling it,
and it's just pulling this
surface and not affecting the
one that you're not touching,
we felt like that gave the
most direct feedback.
And just simply felt the
best to users as we
experimented with it.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
JENS NAGEL: And I also think
that it somewhat has a more
non-modal feel to it in that
if you like a little
navigation helper that you can
pull on screen that does not
give you the impression that
this level that you're pushing
out of the way is directly
linked to the content that
you're pulling onto
the screen.
So the two only have an
indirect hierarchical
relationship.
Whereas, if you push the content
all the way they sort
of feel like they're stuck
together, and one is directly
subordinate to the other.
And that sort of would not work
if you pull in something
from the lower levels
of the screen, as
Richard pointed out earlier.
ROMAN NURIK: Makes sense.
Nick, did you have
any questions?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
I wanted to ask a little bit
more about right hand Drawers.
You touched on it a little
bit in the talking about
Earth and One Today.
But it's not saying we
particularly documented in the
design guidelines.
So the way I see it is we're
kind of sticking to the
general arrangement with
the action bars.
So Navigation is always on the
left, and Actions tend to be
on the right hand side.
So that's the way you see a
break down so it's perfectly
legitimate to use a left hand
Drawer and a right hand
Drawer, or one or the other.
JENS NAGEL: Yeah.
So, definitely.
As we've seen in the example
with Google Earth, one option
could have been to take all
the settings content--
which is not directly
navigation content--
move it over to the right.
But for me, I sometimes break
it down as things on the
right, the actions or settings
that usually are in the
overflow, they're contextual
to the view.
So if I pull in something from
the right, invoke an action,
or do customizations of a view,
they're all directly
related to the view that I'm
currently looking at.
Whereas Navigation is more
at the meta level.
It helps me to reach the
different destinations inside
of my app, whereas the right
hand stuff manipulates the
stuff that I'm currently
looking at.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
So I had two more questions.
I'll ask the first one
first I guess.
So Google Hangouts is another
application that was released
recently, and it actually uses
something that is similar,
somewhat similar to
the Navigation
Drawer, but it's different.
So for developers out there it's
really the differences
between Drawer layout and
Sliding Pane layout.
So can you guys talk a little
bit about the difference
between something like a
Navigation Drawer and
something like what Google
Hangouts uses to kind of have
list of stuff on the left and
details on the right?
RICH FULCHER: Sure.
Sure.
I mean, I think the easiest
way to think about that
difference is to kind of take
a slight step back and think
about how--
what function the different
elements are trying to perform
within each of those contexts.
So the traditional Navigation
Drawer is, in a sense it's, I
want to get away from the
current context and I want to
go somewhere else.
What's currently here isn't
interesting me anymore, so I
want to go elsewhere.
For Hangouts, it's a
slightly different
case, for a few reasons.
One is that, the two panes
that are interacting, for
those who haven't used it, it's
kind of a list of all the
conversations that
I have ongoing.
And then that intersects with
a detailed view of the given
conversation, which appears to
slide in front of it but leave
a slight edge of the
conversation view--
conversation lists
still in place.
That list of conversations is
not as simple as a set of data
objects as a normal Navigation
Drawer would use.
It's not just a label
and perhaps a count.
It's who is in this
conversation, it's an icon
that might be an aggregate
of up to four different
participants, it may have a
snippet what the last message
was and who said it.
If it's an image, it could be
a preview of the image.
If there's a ongoing video
Hangout that's there that may
be indicated.
It may be time stamped.
It has kind of a read,
unread status.
So there's actually a lot of
data that every item in that
conversation list is
communicating.
And it's completely dynamic.
You can swipe it away, you can
archive conversations, new
conversations can come in,
conversations can reorder.
And all of those things make
it kind of significantly
distinct from what we would
traditionally use a Navigation
Drawer for.
So because of those reasons, we
wanted to still have that
sense of the relationship
between the panel and the
notion of, even when I'm within
the detailed view of
one particular Hangout, I can
still see what's going on in
those other Hangouts.
Especially on tablets and
larger form factors.
I can get the sense of, oh,
there's a new message here
because that moved up.
And there's a new person talking
there, perhaps, and
these other ones are just
decaying and they're not
having anything interesting
happen to them.
So it had those properties of
more information, dynamic
content and just the ability to
kind of peek, even without
having to pull the Drawer in on
some devices, that made it,
in our estimation, best to use
as a variation in a sense of
that pattern.
Rather than just going ahead and
just using the Drawer, or
just using a simple hierarchic
list where there's no distinct
relationship.
We want to create a relationship
between those two
spaces, but not quite as
strong as the Drawer.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
That actually folds very nicely
into my last question
that I had.
So some people, some folks,
may need, or may find
themselves in cases where
they need some
sort of dynamic items.
So for example, let's say I have
three major items like
Home, Explorer and
Shop, right.
And then let's say that you
allow the user to Favorite
certain items throughout the--
maybe even Favorite
certain sections.
Like let's say your sports app,
maybe you're Favoriting
certain leagues or certain
teams, even.
What do you guys see as--
or is it appropriate to use,
or to show, these types of
items in Navigation Drawer?
JENS NAGEL: I think it's totally
appropriate, and I
think those collapsible items
are a good way of structuring
this content.
If you think, for example,
about an app like Google
Drive, for example, where you
have certain folders that you
visit regularly.
You could employ something like
a frequency, a recency
scheme, or even an explicit
favorites scheme by starring a
particular folder, in order
to represent this in the
Navigation Drawer to make it
quickly accessible once I get
back to the app.
So I think those dynamic items
are a nice way of making
frequently needed content
more accessible.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
JENS NAGEL: And on top,
the fact that they are
collapsible--
if I can add that--
sort of helps to keep the
entire layout clean.
So if I don't want to look at
those options, I can hide them
and sort of focus on
the pure top level
navigation, for example.
ROMAN NURIK: That makes
perfect sense.
Nick, do you have anything you
want to add real quick before
we sign off?
Or any--
NICK BUTCHER: I wanted to just
pick up on one thing that--
one of my favorite lines in
the pattern in the design
guidelines, says that the
Navigation Drawer isn't a good
fit for every single app out
there and I just wanted you to
talk about that a little bit.
I mean, it's kind of like the
hot new thing, right?
And so lots of cool and
interesting apps are picking
up on this pattern.
I can see lots of people
running towards it just
because it's interesting.
So I think it's really important
to bear in mind some
of the guidelines that Jens
pointed out, like when to use
it [INAUDIBLE].
And also, I would say, don't
be lazy, as well.
If you have this extra space in
Navigation Drawer, you can
see some people might run
towards it and end up just
chucking the kitchen sink in
there because they have the
space to play with, much like
your navigation talk from
Google I/O where you go through
using use cases and
other modeling tools to really
kind of look at your content
to work out what the
major barriers are.
I think that's super important
when deciding what goes in the
Drawer and what shouldn't.
You need to really think
about content.
So I just wanted to say, yeah,
it's an awesome pattern and it
has some really great use
cases, but it's not for
everyone, right?
JENS NAGEL: Exactly.
As you start to structure your
app you really should spend
some time on deciding what
your top level navigation
scheme should be.
And it really should serve
the purpose of your app.
So if your top level navigation
is all about spur
of the moment switching, quick
switching between different
facets, the fixed tabs are the
best way of doing that.
Of course, as you have more top
levels, you're running out
of space there, then you might
have to do something
different, but even in those
cases, if you think about the
Google I/O app from this year,
for example, you can think
about combining certain facets
into one view in order to
still only have three options
in your fixed tabs.
So for example, the Google I/O
app used Explore as one tab
that included maps and, I think,
the different tracks
for the conference.
So here we've sort of took the
maps facet and the tracks
facet and we combined it
into an explore facet.
And the switching between the
facets using the tap control
was still super fast
and accessible.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
And Rich, anything you want
to add before we sign off?
RICH FULCHER: No.
I mean, I'll just echo.
Just don't go with the fad
for the fad's sake.
Be thoughtful.
Something we had a lot of fun
doing for the I/O talk was
just taking the Google apps and
just kind of considering,
well, what if the app you know
and love used a completely
different navigation
structure?
Would that work, what would
that look like,
would that be suitable?
That's an exercise that anybody
can do pretty quickly
just even to pencil sketch it
out, and that, even if you
don't want to think about it
from this very philosophical
viewpoint of how navigation
should work, just drawing it
out and getting a gut sense of
it is pretty significant.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
Well I think we've run way over
time, but this is great
because there's a lot
of good content, a
lot of new good content.
A lot of things that weren't
in the guidelines that we
probably should put in the
guidelines at some point, but
really, really glad to get you
guys take on the Navigation
Drawer and all different
aspects of it.
So with that, thanks everybody
for tuning into a very long
episode of Android
Design in Action.
Tune in, I think, next week or
the week after, for some
pretty interesting more stuff
around Google Play.
I think, yeah, that's
it for this episode.
So thanks.
RICH FULCHER: Great.
JENS NAGEL: Thanks
for having us.
RICH FULCHER: Yeah, thanks.